(HOST) IRA GLASS: As early as I remember, I was afraid to go to sleep. This began when I was six. My uncle Lenny went off to Vietnam. And that opened up this chapter in my life where I was obsessed with death. I was scared that uncle Lenny was going to be killed. But more than that, his absence underscored the fact that some day, no matter what, I was going to be drafted and I'd have to go to Vietnam and I'd be killed. And there was nothing that I or anybody I knew could do to stop that.
在我记事起，我就害怕睡觉。这种恐惧从我六岁时开始。我的莱尼叔叔去了越南。那开启了我人生中一段痴迷于死亡的时期。我害怕莱尼叔叔会被杀害。但不仅如此，他的离去更加强调了一个事实：无论如何，总有一天我也会被征召入伍，不得不去越南，然后被杀掉。对于阻止这一切，我和我认识的任何人都没有办法。
I knew I was going to be killed because I was chubby and I was terrible at sports. I could barely run half a block. On TV, wars seemed to involve a lot of running. There was crouching, there was shooting, but there was a disturbing amount of running. So I was six and I knew I was going to die and my mom and dad couldn't help me. Nobody could help me. I'll be dead forever. Galaxies would spin. Humans would travel to other worlds. And I would miss all of that. Nobody would remember me or anybody that I had ever known forever.
我知道我会被杀掉，因为我很胖，而且体育很差。我连半个街区都跑不完。电视上的战争似乎总是涉及大量的奔跑。有蹲伏、有射击，但有极其令人不安的大量奔跑镜头。所以我六岁时就知道我注定要死，而我的爸爸妈妈帮不了我。没人能帮我。我将永远死去。星系会旋转，人类会前往其他世界，而我将错过这一切。没人会记得我或我所认识的任何人，直到永远。
And I would lie awake at night, scared to fall asleep, because sleep seemed no different than death. You know. You were gone, not moving, not talking, not thinking, not aware-- not aware. What could be more frightening? What could be bigger? And here was the weird part of it, I thought when I was a kid. Somehow every night all the adults, all my relatives, every teacher, everybody who I'd ever heard of headed off for bed like this was no big deal. Complete annihilation. No big deal.
我会在夜晚躺着，不敢入睡，因为睡觉似乎和死亡没什么两样。你知道，你就这样消失了，不动、不说话、不思考、没意识——没意识。还有什么比这更可怕的吗？还有什么比这更严重的事吗？当时还是小孩的我，觉得最奇怪的一点是：每天晚上，所有的成年人、我的亲戚、每一位老师，我所听说的每一个人，似乎都像没事一样去睡觉。彻底的毁灭，居然没事。
For those of us who fear sleep, there is a lot to fear. And that's what we're going to talk about on today's radio show. It's a survey of this altered state-- this altered state where we're vulnerable and just gone. Having dreams where anything at all can happen. Not in control of our own bodies.
对于我们这些害怕睡觉的人来说，确实有很多值得害怕的地方。这就是我们今天广播节目要讨论的话题。我们将探讨这种改变的状态——这种我们脆弱且完全消失的改变状态。做着任何事都可能发生的梦，无法掌控自己的身体。
Listen to what happened to this woman. Denise.
听听这个女人的遭遇。丹妮丝。
It wasn't until I was maybe, I don't know, eight or nine years old that one day I woke up and it was like my eyes were open. I was looking around. I just couldn't move. I couldn't move my arms or my legs. I couldn't turn my head. And I felt this, like, weight on my chest. And the first thing I thought was, oh my god. What happened to me? Was I in a car accident?
直到我大概八九岁的时候，有一天我醒来，感觉就像眼睛睁开了。我在环顾四周。我就是动弹不得。我没法移动双臂或双腿，也无法转动头部。我感觉到胸口有种重压感。我第一个念头是，天哪，我怎么了？我是出车祸了吗？
It lasted for, I don't know, maybe 30 seconds to a minute. And then I just kind of snapped out of it. And I was really freaked out. And I went and told my mom, I think something is wrong with me. And my family's Mexican. And in Mexico they have this superstition that they say the devil is sitting on your chest when that happens to you. And she said, oh don't worry. That's just the devil sitting on your chest. Like that's supposed to make me feel better.
这种情况持续了大概30秒到一分钟。然后我突然摆脱了那种状态。我当时被吓坏了。我跑去告诉妈妈，我觉得自己出了毛病。我们家是墨西哥人，在墨西哥有一种迷信说法，说当这种情况发生时，是恶魔坐在你的胸口上。她说，噢，别担心，那只是恶魔坐在你的胸口上。好像这样说就能让我感觉好受点似的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: As Denise got older, this paralysis has happened more and more. And sometimes when she's lying there paralyzed and awake, she hallucinates. She sees family members who aren't there or she hears them. And sometimes they're mad at her. Though the only time all this happens to Denise is when she takes a nap during the day.
随着丹妮丝长大，这种瘫痪发作得越来越频繁。有时当她瘫痪地躺在那里清醒着时，她会出现幻觉。她会看到不在场的家人，或者听到他们的声音。有时他们还会对她生气。不过，所有这些情况只发生在丹妮丝白天打盹的时候。
I've definitely avoided taking naps, no matter how tired I was. I mean, I forced myself to survive on like five or six hours of sleep-- very little sleep.
我绝对避免打盹，不管我有多累。我是说，我强迫自己靠五六个小时的睡眠生存——极少的睡眠。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: It's like that movie where what's his name appears as soon as you fall asleep.
就像那部电影，那个人一睡着就出现了。
Freddy Krueger.
弗莱迪·克鲁格。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Yeah. Freddy Krueger. Right. Yeah.
是的。弗莱迪·克鲁格。没错。是的。
In college it was happening to me so regularly that I basically survived on Red Bull and not much else.
上大学时，这种情况发生得非常频繁，我基本上只靠红牛维持，别的几乎什么都不吃。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Then there's Ron Vagley. He'd wake up after an hour or two of sleep and find himself, for example, still in bed, there with his wife.
接着是罗恩·瓦格利。他会在睡着一两个小时后醒来，发现自己——比如，还在床上，和他的妻子在一起。
(SUBJECT) RON VAGLEY: A couple times I had my hands around her neck,, choking her until I came out of it.
有几次我的双手掐着她的脖子，一直掐到我清醒过来。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: She would just wake you up? Is that it?
她会把你叫醒吗？是这样吗？
(SUBJECT) RON VAGLEY: Well, yeah. She'd start screaming. And then I would kind of come out of it.
嗯，是的。她会开始尖叫。然后我就会从那种状态中脱离出来。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Was it hard for you to see this side of yourself? You know what I mean? Like you wake up and your hands are around the throat of the person who you love.
看到自己这一面很难受吗？你懂我的意思吗？比如你醒来发现双手正掐着你爱人的喉咙。
(SUBJECT) RON VAGLEY: Well, yeah. It was hard. And I was worried that I was going to hurt somebody. Like hurt my kids or my wife. And I felt miserable in the day thinking about what I did.
嗯，是的。很难受。我很担心自己会伤害到别人。比如伤害我的孩子或妻子。白天想到我做过的事，我就感到痛苦万分。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: You must have dreaded going to bed?
你一定很害怕睡觉吧？
(SUBJECT) RON VAGLEY: Yep. I mean you're going to sleep, tired, knowing that this is going to happen. Yeah. It wasn't much fun.
是啊。你是说你带着疲惫去睡觉，却知道这种事还会发生。是的。那一点也不好玩。
Aaaah! Aaaah!
啊！啊！
(SUBJECT) CARLOS SCHENCK: We have just witnessed a vivid example of a night terror of pavor nocturnus associated with violent behavior. This episode arose abruptly from slow wave or delta sleep. Nocturnal seizures--
我们刚刚见证了一个与暴力行为相关的夜惊症或惊恐发作的生动例子。这一幕突然从慢波睡眠或深睡期中出现。夜间癫痫——
(HOST) IRA GLASS: This from a DVD put together by Doctors Carlos Schenk and Mark Mahowald of the Minnesota Regional Sleep Disorder Center. The number of adults with troubled sleep, they say, is a lot higher than you probably think. 4% of all adults have sleepwalking episodes. That's 8 million Americans. Another 2% engage in sleep related violence. People eat when they're asleep. They have sex when they're asleep.
这是卡洛斯·申克医生和马克·马霍瓦尔德医生从明尼苏达地区睡眠障碍中心制作的一张DVD中摘取的片段。他们说，患有睡眠障碍的成年人数量远比你想象的要多。所有成年人中有4%的人有梦游发作。那是800万美国人。另外2%的人会进行与睡眠相关的暴力行为。人们会在睡梦中进食，会在睡梦中做爱。
And one of the most affecting things to watch on this DVD that they assembled to educate people about various sleep disorders is a 51-year-old Japanese man who was videotaped while having a bad dream.
在他们为教育大众关于各种睡眠障碍而制作的这张DVD中，最令人感触的镜头之一是一位51岁的日本男子的视频，他在做恶梦时被录了下来。
Oooh! [SLEEP CRIES]
喔！[睡梦中的哭喊]
(HOST) IRA GLASS: The man later told researchers that in this dream he's fighting off snakes. And in this kind of grainy, nighttime footage you can see him swat away snakes with his arms. He kicks at one with his foot. The metal sound you're hearing is the bed frame. Finally he picks up a pillow like it's a rock and beats one away. There's something completely naked about this footage. It's very strange to watch another person at a moment when they are so totally vulnerable and alone and terrified.
这名男子后来告诉研究人员，在梦中他正在和蛇搏斗。在这段昏暗的夜间录像中，你可以看到他用手臂拍打蛇。他用脚踢开其中一条。你听到的金属声是床架的声音。最后，他抓起一个枕头当作石头，把其中一条打跑。这段录像有着某种完全赤裸的特质。看着另一个人在如此完全脆弱、孤独和恐惧的时刻，感觉非常奇怪。
From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, Fear of Sleep. We have five stories of people who either have a huge fear of sleep or, frankly, they should have a huge fear of sleep.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，这是由国际公共广播电台发行的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是：对睡眠的恐惧。我们有五个关于人们的故事，他们要么极度恐惧睡眠，要么说实话，他们确实应该感到极度恐惧。
Act one, Stranger in the Night, act two, Sleep's Tiniest Enemies, act three, The Bitter Fruits of Wakefulness, act four, Hollywood Induced Nightmare, act five, A Small Taste of the Big Sleep. Stay with us.
第一幕，黑夜中的陌生人；第二幕，睡眠的最微小敌人；第三幕，清醒的苦果；第四幕，好莱坞引发的噩梦；第五幕，长眠的一小口滋味。请继续收听。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act One. Stranger in the Night.
第一幕。黑夜中的陌生人。
There's a poem by Raymond Carver that goes, "I woke up with a spot of blood over my eye. A scratch halfway across my forehead. But I'm sleeping alone these days. Why on earth would a man raise his hand against himself, even in sleep. It's this and similar questions I'm trying to answer this morning, as I study my face in the window."
雷蒙德·卡佛有一首诗写道：“我醒来，眼皮上有一点血迹。额头上有一道划痕。但我这些日子都是独自一人睡觉。一个人为什么会在睡梦中对自己举手呢？这就是我今早注视窗户中自己的脸时，试图回答的这类问题。”
Well, that is probably about as good an introduction as you could get for this first story from Mike Birbiglia. He told it in front of a live audience at The Moth in New York.
嗯，这大概就是迈克·比比利亚这个故事最好的开场白了。他在纽约“飞蛾”故事大赛的现场观众面前讲述了这个故事。
(SUBJECT) MIKE BIRBIGLIA: About seven years ago I started walking in my sleep. And I would have these recurring dreams that there was a hovering insect-like jackal in our bedroom. And I was living with my girlfriend at the time. And I would jump on the bed and I would strike a karate pose. I'd never taken karate, but I had the books from Book Fair. And I would say, Abby-- that was my girlfriend-- there's a jackal in the room. And she got so used to it, she could talk me down while remaining asleep. She said, "There's not a jackal in the room. Go to bed." And I would say, "Are you sure?" And she would say, "Yes, Michael. Go to bed. There's no jackal." And I would say, "OK." And I would go to bed knowing that there was a jackal. And that's trust.
大约七年前，我开始梦游。我会反复做同一个梦，梦见我们的卧室里有一只盘旋的、像昆虫一样的豺狼。那时我和女朋友住在一起。我会跳到床上，摆出一个空手道姿势。我从未学过空手道，但我有书展买的书。我会说，艾比——那是我的女朋友——房间里有只豺狼。她已经习惯了，她能在睡梦中安抚我。她说，“房间里没有豺狼。去睡觉。”我会问，“你确定吗？”她说，“是的，迈克尔。去睡觉。没有豺狼。”我说，“好吧。”于是我带着房间里有豺狼的认知去睡觉。这就是信任。
It was around that time I had a dream that I was in the Olympics for some kind of arbitrary event like dust-bustering. And they told me I got third place. And I stood up on the third place podium. And I'm feeling good about myself. I'm new to the sport, you know. And they say, "You know, actually we reconsidered and you got first place." And I was like, oh, that's a marvelous promotion. I got first place.
就在那段时间，我做了一个梦，梦见我参加了奥运会，项目是某种随意的比赛，比如用吸尘器清理灰尘。他们告诉我我得了第三名。我站在第三名的领奖台上，对自己感觉很不错。我是这项运动的新手，你知道的。然后他们说，“其实我们重新考虑了，你得了第一名。”我心想，噢，那真是个极好的晋升。我得了第一名。
And I move over to the first place podium and it starts wobbling. And it's wobbling and wobbling. And I wake up. And I'm falling off the top of our bookcase in our living room.
于是我走到第一名的领奖台上，它开始晃动。它一直在晃，晃得不停。然后我醒了。我正从客厅书柜顶上摔下来。
And I land on the floor, hard, on top of our Tivo. And it broke into pieces. And I'm disoriented on the floor. It's like one of these stories where people black out drinking. And they wake up in Idaho. And they don't know where they are. And they're like, oh no. Hardee's. Or whatever is there. But it was in my own living room. I was just like, oh no. Tivo pieces. And I went to bed. And Abby woke me up in the morning and she said, "Michael, what happened to the Tivo?" And I said, "I got first place. And it's a long story."
我重重地摔在地上，正好压在我们的Tivo机上。它碎成了碎片。我瘫在地上，头晕目眩。就像那些喝断片的人的故事一样，他们在爱达荷州醒来，不知道自己在哪里，心想，噢不，这是哪里。但这是在我的客厅里。我只是心想，噢不，Tivo碎了。然后我回去睡觉。艾比早上叫醒我，说，“迈克尔，Tivo怎么了？”我说，“我得了第一名。说来话长。”
So at this point I thought, maybe I should see a doctor. And then I thought, maybe I'll eat dinner. Because that seems more convenient. But a lot of people would say this to me. My parents-- you know, my dad's a doctor. He'd say, "You know you should really see a doctor." And I remember saying, "I'm really busy." Ahhh. And thinking these people were crazy. Like, they don't know how busy I am. And so I never went to a doctor.
所以那时我想，也许我该去看医生。然后我又想，还是先吃晚饭吧，因为那样更方便。但很多人都曾这样对我说。我的父母——你知道，我爸爸是医生。他会说，“你应该真的去看医生。”我记得我说，“我真的很忙。”啊。而且我觉得这些人疯了。好像他们不知道我有多忙。所以我一直没去看医生。
But I did purchase a book by a doctor named Dr. Dement, which is not the most calming name for a sleep doctor. But it's called The Promise of Sleep . And I learned-- and these are in Helpful Tips-- I learned turn off cable news or the news before bed, turn off your cell phone, turn off the internet, your computer. You know, don't have big meals, that kind of thing. And I came across in the sleep disorders, a disorder that resembled symptoms of mine. And it was called REM behavior disorder. And people who have this have a dopamine deficiency. And dopamine's the chemical that's released from your brain into your body that paralyzes your body when you fall asleep so that you don't do what's in your brain. So I thought, maybe I have this. And then I thought, maybe I'll eat dinner.
但我确实买了一本医生写的书，名叫《睡眠的承诺》，作者是迪门特医生，这对睡眠医生来说可不是个让人安心的名字。但我学到了——这些都是实用建议——我学到了睡前关掉有线新闻或新闻节目，关掉手机，关掉互联网和电脑。你知道，不要暴饮暴食之类的。我在睡眠障碍中读到了一种与我的症状相似的疾病，叫REM（快速眼动）睡眠行为障碍。患有这种疾病的人多巴胺缺乏。多巴胺是一种从大脑释放到身体的化学物质，能在你入睡时麻痹身体，防止你把梦境付诸行动。所以我心想，也许我得了这个。然后我又想，还是先吃晚饭吧。
So I never went to see a doctor until about three years ago. I was performing in a college in Walla Walla, Washington. I'm a comedian by trade. And I was staying at a hotel called on La Quinta Inn. And some people correct me. No. No. No. It's La Kinta. That's not fair. You can't force me to speak Spanish. I'm at La Kinta Inn in Vwalla Vwalla Washington and I fell asleep watching the news. And it was sort of a story about war and something very chaotic. And I fell asleep. And I had a dream that there was a guided missile headed towards my room. And there's all these military personnel in the room with me. And I jumped out of bed and I'm like what's the plan? And they say, its come to our attention the missile coordinates are set specifically on you.
所以我直到三年前才去看医生。当时我在华盛顿州瓦拉瓦拉的一所大学演出。我的职业是喜剧演员。我住在一家叫“拉昆塔”的旅馆里。有些人纠正我，不，不，不。是“拉金塔”。这不公平。你不能强迫我讲西班牙语。我在华盛顿州瓦拉瓦拉的拉金塔旅馆，看着新闻睡着了。那是一个关于战争和某种非常混乱的新闻。我睡着了。我做了一个梦，梦见一枚导弹正朝着我的房间飞来。房间里全都是军事人员。我跳下床，问道，计划是什么？他们说，我们注意到导弹坐标正是针对你的。
And I thought, that's very bad. Because I don't have a plan for that one. So I decided to jump out the window in my dream. And as it turns out, in my life. And there are two important details. One, I was on the second floor of La Quinta Inn and two, the window was closed. So I jumped through a window like the Hulk. And I say that because that's how I described it at the emergency room in Walla Walla, Washington. I was like you know the Hulk? He just kind of jumps through stuff. So I jump through the window and I scream, aaaaahh!
我想，那很糟。因为我对此没有任何计划。所以我决定在梦里跳出窗户。结果，在现实生活中也是如此。有两个重要的细节。第一，我在拉金塔旅馆的二楼；第二，窗户是关着的。于是我像绿巨人一样跳过了窗户。我之所以这么说，是因为我在华盛顿州瓦拉瓦拉的急诊室里就是这样描述的。我说，你知道绿巨人吗？他就是那样跳过东西的。所以我跳过窗户，尖叫道，啊！
And what was remarkable is that people of this disorder are capable of doing things they couldn't do in their everyday life. It's like blacking out drinking where you don't feel any pain or inhibition. I jumped through a second story window and I landed on the front lawn of the hotel. I took a spill. I got back up and I kept running. And I'm running and I'm slowly realizing I'm on the front lawn of La Kinta Inn in Vwalla Vwalla, Washington in my underwear, bleeding. And I'm like, oh no.
令人惊奇的是，患有这种障碍的人能够做到他们在日常生活中做不到的事情。就像喝断片一样，你感觉不到任何痛苦或克制。我跳过了二楼的窗户，摔在了旅馆的前草坪上。我摔得很重，但我爬起来继续跑。我跑着，慢慢意识到自己只穿内衣裤在华盛顿州瓦拉瓦拉的拉金塔旅馆前草坪上，还流着血。我就心想，噢不。
And it was one of those rare moments in your life where in retrospect you're like, what the hell? And at the time you're like, I guess I'll walk to the front desk and explain what happened. Fortunately the person working at the front desk was mildly retarded. And I say fortunately because he was completely unfazed by what had just happened. It's 3:00 in the morning. The phones are ringing off the hook from people staying at the hotel who just saw the guy jump out the window, screaming.
那是你人生中罕见的瞬间之一，回想起来你会心想，搞什么鬼？而当时你心想，我想我还是走到前台去解释一下发生了什么。幸运的是，在前台工作的那个人有点智障。我说幸运的是，因为他对我刚刚发生的事情完全无动于衷。那是凌晨3点。旅馆里的电话铃响个不停，全都是刚看到那个家伙尖叫着跳出窗户的住客。
I'm bleeding, in my underwear, and I say, "Hello." Because as it turns out, you have to start somewhere. I'm staying at the hotel-- credibility. I had an incident wherein I jumped out of my window. I am bleeding and I need to go to a hospital. And I'll never forget his reaction because he just goes, uh-unnn. And I thought, this is the best possible reaction i could receive at this juncture.
我满身是血，穿着内衣，我说，“你好。”因为事实证明，你总得从某处开始。我住在这个旅馆——为了增加可信度。我发生了一个事故，我从窗户跳出来了。我流血了，我需要去医院。我永远不会忘记他的反应，因为他只是说，嗯。我想，这是我在这种境况下能得到的最好的反应。
And so I drove myself to the hospital. I checked myself into the emergency room. I had to explain what happened three times-- the nurse and the doctor and the front desk. I'm the Hulk. I'm the Hulk. I'm the Hulk. And the doctor, God bless him, worked on me until about 5:30 in the morning. And he put 30 stitches in my arms and in my legs. And he is an emergency room doctor and even he is like, you should be dead. And I was like, no you should. I zinged him. And about 5:30 I drove back to the hotel and I checked out. And I actually paid for the window like any good window jumper would. And it was $300 for the window and about $49 for the room.
于是我自己开车去了医院。我办理了急诊入院。我不得不解释发生了什么三次——分别是对护士、医生和前台。我是绿巨人。我是绿巨人。我是绿巨人。上帝保佑那位医生，他一直为我工作到凌晨5点半。他在我的胳膊和腿上缝了30针。他是一位急诊室医生，连他都说，你不死真是奇迹。我说，不，你应该去死。我反讽了他一下。大约5点半，我开车回到旅馆退房。我确实像任何一个跳窗户的好市民一样赔偿了窗户。窗户花了300美元，房费花了49美元。
And I went back to New York. And I did what I should have done in the first place when I saw the jackal. I went to a doctor who specializes in sleepwalk disorders. And now when I go to bed at night, I take a very strong pill and I sleep in a sleeping bag up to my neck. And I wear mittens so I can't open the sleeping bag.
然后我回到了纽约。我做了我第一次看到豺狼时就该做的事。我去找了一位专门研究梦游障碍的医生。现在我晚上睡觉时，会吃一片强力药片，然后睡在一直拉到脖子的睡袋里。我还戴着连指手套，这样我就没法打开睡袋。
And so in closing, I think that if it weren't for denial, I wouldn't be a comedian because to be a comedian you have to go on stage those first few years and bomb. And then walk off stage and think, that went great. Because otherwise you'd never get on stage the next night. You would just think, human beings don't like me. But sometimes denial can kill you. Thank you very much.
最后我想说，如果不是因为否认，我就不会成为喜剧演员。因为要成为喜剧演员，你必须在前几年上台演出时搞砸。然后走下台，心想，表现得真棒。因为否则你永远不会第二天再上台。你只会觉得，人类不喜欢我。但有时否认会让你丧命。非常感谢。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Mike Birbiglia, performing an excerpt from his one man show, "Sleepwalk With Me". He's about to embark on a national tour where he tells stories and does comedy, from Cape Cod to Los Angeles, starting in August. Catch him before he becomes too famous. He's all over to the ITunes store and the internet, Google any spelling of his name, or go to our show's website. He was recorded at The Moth, where people tell stories from their own lives on stage. They have a free podcast-- free. And a website with all kinds of stories like the one you just heard. They are at themoth.org.
迈克·比比利亚，表演了他的独角戏《与我梦游》的片段。他即将开始全国巡演，从科德角到洛杉矶，八月份开始。在他变得太出名之前去看看他吧。他在iTunes商店和互联网上随处可见，搜索他名字的任何拼写，或访问我们节目的网站。他是录制于“飞蛾”故事大赛，人们在那里讲述他们生活中真实的故事。他们有一个免费的播客——免费的。还有一个网站，上面有各种像你刚刚听到的那样的故事。他们的网址是themoth.org。
And OK, one last part here and I'll swear I'll stop. If you have a sleep disorder of the sort we've been talking about so far today, there is very effective treatment. See a doctor. There's a little pill called Klonopin that helps most cases, as Birbiglia said. The DVD that Dr. Carlos Schenck made explaining sleep disorders that we heard an excerpt of at the top of the show is called Sleep Runners and it is on the web at sleeprunners.com. Dr. Schenck also has this beautifully put together book about all called Paradox Lost.
好了，最后再说一点，我就发誓不再说了。如果你有我们今天讨论的那种睡眠障碍，这里有非常有效的治疗方法。去看医生吧。有一种叫氯硝西泮的小药片可以帮助大多数病例，正如比比利亚所说。卡洛斯·申克医生制作的那张解释睡眠障碍的DVD，我们今天节目开头听到了片段，名字叫《睡眠奔跑者》，网址是sleeprunners.com。申克医生还有一本关于这一切的精美著作，叫《悖论丢失》。
[MUSIC - "TO GET TO SLEEP" BY BRITISH SEA POWER]
[音乐 - 《为了入睡》 BY 英国海洋力量乐队]
Act Two. Sleep's Tiniest Enemies.
第二幕。睡眠的最微小敌人。
We now turn to people who battle at night, but not with their own dreams. And these people battle critters-- living creatures of the night. One of the producers of our show, Nancy Updike, has been looking into this.
现在我们转向那些在深夜奋战的人，但不是与自己的梦境作战。这些人与害虫——深夜的活生物——作战。我们节目的制作人之一南希·厄普代克一直在调查这件事。
(HOST) NANCY UPDIKE: I talked to a woman in Baltimore with an unusual name. And she doesn't want that name linked in anyone's mind with a house full of pests. So I agreed to call her Miss M on the radio. Miss M has had some very bad nighttime experiences with roaches starting with her old place on Liberty Heights Avenue.
我和巴尔的摩的一位名字很不寻常的女士谈过。她不想让那个名字与满屋子害虫联系起来。所以我同意在电台上称她为M小姐。M小姐有过一些非常糟糕的夜间经历，蟑螂，始于她在自由高地大道上的老住处。
(SUBJECT) MISS M: It was about 2:00 o'clock in the morning. I was laying on the couch. And I was on the couch because all the rooms was full. And I just felt something in my ear. And so I knew exactly what it was when I felt it. And it was making this sshhusshhusshhu. And I jumped up and I started screaming. My, my [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. She came up to the room. We told everybody else in the house we were on our way to the hospital. He stuck this thing in my ear about this long. Pulled it out. It didn't take but a minute to get out.
大约是凌晨2点。我躺在沙发上。我之所以在沙发上是因为所有房间都满了。然后我感觉到耳朵里有什么东西。我感觉到的时候就知道那是什么了。它发出了那种嗖嗖嗖的声音。我跳起来开始尖叫。我的……她来到房间。我们告诉屋里其他人我们要去医院。他把这东西插进我耳朵里大概这么长。把它拉了出来。没花一分钟就弄出来了。
(INTERVIEWER) NANCY UPDIKE: And he showed to you. And it was a roach.
他给你看了。是一只蟑螂。
(SUBJECT) MISS M: He showed it to me.
他给我看了。
(INTERVIEWER) NANCY UPDIKE: How big was it?
多大？
(SUBJECT) MISS M: It was a big one. It was a big one. No little tiny one. It cost about $165 to get it out. That doctor gonna charge me.
挺大的。是个大家伙。不是那种小不点。花了我165美元才弄出来。医生收了我这么多。
(HOST) NANCY UPDIKE: Miss M doesn't live in that place anymore. She lives in a small house in O'Donnell Heights. The house is tidy, but it's public housing and it has serious multiple infestations. The mice in Miss M's apartment have abated temporarily this week for some reason, which has left the gluey mouse traps free for armies of roaches to get stuck on. Every sticky rectangle has dozens of roaches on it, waving their doomed antennae. And yet in spite of the glue traps, the Raid, the Boric acid, there are still roaches in every drawer she pulls open for me, every cabinet, the sink. They mill by the hinges of closet doors, they saunter down the walls, absolutely unafraid. Nighttime, of course, is the worst.
M小姐已经不住那个地方了。她住在奥唐奈高地的一栋小房子里。房子很整洁，但那是公共住房，有着严重的多种虫害。M小姐公寓里的老鼠本周因为某种原因暂时减少了，这让胶鼠板腾出来给成群的蟑螂粘住。每一个粘胶长方形上都有几十只蟑螂在挥动它们注定死亡的触角。然而，尽管有粘胶板、雷达喷雾和硼酸，她在给我拉开的每个抽屉、每个橱柜、水槽里依然有蟑螂。它们在壁橱门的合页边穿梭，在墙上漫步，完全不害怕。当然，夜间是最糟糕的。
Miss M's daughter Brittany, without even hearing her mother's roach in ear story, told me she got a roach in her ear too, not just once.
M小姐的女儿布列塔尼，甚至都没听过她妈妈那次蟑螂进耳朵的故事，告诉我她也经历过蟑螂进耳朵，而且不止一次。
Twice. Got in my ear twice. And one had got in my boyfriend's ear. We had to go to the emergency room.
两次。两次进我耳朵。还有一次进我男朋友耳朵里了。我们不得不去急诊室。
(INTERVIEWER) NANCY UPDIKE: Was it hard to go to sleep after they got in your ear? Was it scary?
那次之后去睡觉难吗？会害怕吗？
I thought of putting tissue in my ear so they can't bother me as much. But yeah, it was hard to go to sleep. They crawled on the bed. I didn't like it. Yeah, it was hard. It was very hard. Because it was a lot.
我想过在耳朵里塞纸巾，这样它们就不能那么打扰我了。但是的，睡觉确实很难。它们在床上爬。我不喜欢。是的，很难。非常难。因为实在是太多了。
(HOST) NANCY UPDIKE: A lot is exactly the problem, Miss M says.
M小姐说，太多正是问题所在。
(SUBJECT) MISS M: You got to have a lot of roaches in your house to get them in your ear. Because there's one or two they not going for your ear. They looking for some food.
你家里得有很多蟑螂才会钻进耳朵里。因为如果只有一两只，它们是不会钻进你耳朵的。它们在找吃的。
(INTERVIEWER) NANCY UPDIKE: They just end up in your ear by mistake.
它们只是不小心钻进你耳朵的。
(SUBJECT) MISS M: Yeah. Yeah. By mistake. And then they can't go backwards. So they can't come out. Roaches only crawl one way.
是的。是的。不小心。然后它们没法往后退。所以它们出不来了。蟑螂只会往前爬。
(HOST) NANCY UPDIKE: Miss M says she's not looking to move. The neighborhood's pretty safe. There's no gunfire at night. The kids can play outside. And she's not mad at the city, her landlord. She's lived with roaches for a long time. And her expectations for getting rid of them, pretty low. She's gracious letting me ask questions about how many bugs she and her family deal with every night. Is it 500? --5,000? But she also makes clear that for her the questions are beside the point.
M小姐说她不打算搬家。社区还算安全。晚上没有枪声。孩子们可以在外面玩。她也不生政府或房东的气。她和蟑螂一起生活很久了。她对消灭它们的期望值很低。她大方地让我询问她和家人每天晚上处理多少虫子。是500只？还是5000只？但她也清楚地表明，对她来说，这些问题都不重要。
(SUBJECT) MISS M: Do you have to say anything about roaches? I don't think about roaches. It's the normal thing around here. We just live with it. We just live with it.
关于蟑螂你还要说什么吗？我根本不去想蟑螂。这在这里是常事。我们只是和它们一起生活。我们只是和它们一起生活。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: That story from Nancy Updike. And oh, we are not done. We are not done with the critters that make people scared to climb inside their own beds. These people that you're about to hear, they all live in the same apartment building.
以上是南希·厄普代克带来的报道。噢，我们还没讲完。那些让人们害怕爬进自己床铺的生物还没讲完。接下来你们要听的这些人，他们都住在同一栋公寓楼里。
(SUBJECT) TENANT 1: We didn't know exactly what it was, but something was biting us.
我们不确定那到底是什么，但有什么东西在咬我们。
(SUBJECT) TENANT 2: But I always complained to my wife, look at this. You know what I mean. You know something biting me.
但我总是向妻子抱怨，看看这个。你知道我什么意思吗。你知道有什么东西在咬我。
(SUBJECT) TENANT 3: We're pretty sure that they're coming from inside the walls and maybe up through the floorboards.
我们很确定它们是从墙里面出来的，可能还穿过了地板。
(SUBJECT) TENANT 4: And I told my husband, I said I seen bed bugs.
我告诉丈夫，我说我看见臭虫了。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: This July at 349 Saint John's Place in Brooklyn, you would be able to tell that the bed bugs had returned by the amount of furniture being thrown out on the curb. If you walked down the block you'd see mattresses and bookcases spray painted with the words "Bed Bugs-- Do Not Use" in big letters to warn off neighbors who might think of taking the stuff home.
今年七月，在布鲁克林圣约翰广场349号，通过路边扔掉的家具数量，你就能看出臭虫卷土重来了。如果你沿着街走，你会看到床垫和书架上喷漆写着大大的“臭虫——禁止使用”，以警告那些可能想把东西带回家的人。
Robyn Semien, another one of our producers, stopped inside.
我们另一位制作人罗宾·塞米恩进去看了一下。
(HOST) ROBYN SEMIEN: Though Stephanie agreed to talk to me, at first she didn't want to invite me inside her apartment. She and her husband and five-year-old daughter never have guests over and haven't for years because of the bed bugs. Like Miss M, she asked that we not give her real name. Her kids got to go to school and she's got to deal with moms who might hear this on the radio. So that's why I'm calling her Stephanie. Her sleep is interrupted all the time by bed bugs, by the full-grown ones that are brown and easy to spot and the babies, that are just little white specks.
虽然斯蒂芬妮同意跟我交谈，但起初她不想让我进她的公寓。她和丈夫还有五岁的女儿已经好几年没有请过客了，原因就是臭虫。像M小姐一样，她要求我们不要透露她的真实姓名。她的孩子得上学，她得应付可能在电台上听到这些的妈妈们。这就是为什么我叫她斯蒂芬妮。她的睡眠总是被臭虫打断，那些棕色、容易发现的成年臭虫，还有那些只是小白点的小臭虫。
Waking up in the middle of the night, sometimes you'll find them and they're white and then their belly is filled with your blood. And sort of their belly is all red. And you can see it. But once I realized that there are these little white things and I was sleeping on white sheets with little blue dots. And then that's when the sheets felt like they were crawling, which is really unmistakable and so hard to sleep in a bed where you feel like the sheets are crawling.
半夜醒来，有时你会发现它们是白色的，然后它们的肚子装满了你的血。它们的肚子变红了。你可以看出来。但有一次我意识到有这些小小白东西时，我睡在有蓝色小圆点的白色床单上。然后那一刻床单感觉好像在爬动，那感觉真的太明显了，睡在一张感觉床单都在爬动的床上太难了。
When I would wake up with bites, if I found them or didn't find them I knew more bites were coming. So the process of going back to sleep is filled with thoughts of more bugs coming.
当我被咬醒时，无论我有没有发现它们，我都知道更多的叮咬还在后面。所以重新入睡的过程充满了更多虫子会来的念头。
(HOST) ROBYN SEMIEN: The bed bugs didn't take over the building overnight. Like many of the residents, they have been there for years, locked in a tug of war where sometimes the residents are winning and sometimes it's the bugs.
臭虫并不是一夜之间占领这栋楼的。像许多住户一样，它们已经在那里待了很多年，陷入了一场拉锯战，有时住户赢了，有时是虫子赢了。
When the bugs arrived, Stephanie's daughter was just two. And started waking up in the middle of the night scratching and crying. Stephanie and her husband moved her to a different room and pretty soon had to relocate themselves too, out of their own bedroom to sleep on an air mattress in the living room. This was a complete failure. The bugs followed. It turns out, Stephanie says, they'd simply moved the bugs' food source. The food source being them. And they drove her crazy.
当虫子来的时候，斯蒂芬妮的女儿才两岁。她开始在半夜又抓又哭地醒来。斯蒂芬妮和丈夫把她换到了另一个房间，没过多久，他们自己也不得不搬出去，从卧室搬到了客厅的充气床上。这是一个彻底的失败。虫子也跟了过来。斯蒂芬妮说，结果他们只是把虫子的食物来源搬走了。食物来源就是他们。这把她逼疯了。
Think about in the middle of the night, there's a lot of adrenaline in the middle of the night. These like middle of the night bites and trying to figure out where they were. I mean it's not just sort of you're waking up and scratching and you're sleepy. Like I would wake up in full combat mode: Rage, rage, rage, rage. And then back to bed. It sucks.
想想半夜的时候，半夜里肾上腺素很高。这些半夜的叮咬，还有试图弄清楚它们在哪里。我的意思是，这不仅仅是你醒来抓一抓，然后昏昏欲睡。我会处于完全战斗模式：愤怒、愤怒、愤怒、愤怒。然后回床上。糟透了。
I definitely upped my coffee intake during that time. I mean I was needing to compensate for the fact that I wasn't getting a full night's sleep. I think it made me a little more twisted. I was feeling a little twisted-- dark. There's a feeling of, like, I am being assaulted and there's nothing I can do.
那段时间我绝对增加了咖啡摄入量。我是说我需要补偿我没有获得充足睡眠的事实。我觉得这让我变得有点扭曲。我感觉有点扭曲——阴暗。有一种被袭击的感觉，而且我无能为力。
(HOST) ROBYN SEMIEN: Stephanie and her husband exterminated. They bought their own pesticides. They put all of their clothes, sheets, towels, pillows, and all of their daughter's toys in clean plastic bags and lived out of the plastic bags. They threw out half the books they owned and then vacuumed the bugs out of each page of the books they kept. Put them in plastic bags. They coated the legs of their beds in Vaseline because Stephanie read somewhere that the bed bugs couldn't climb on Vaseline. They couldn't afford to move.
斯蒂芬妮和丈夫尝试过灭虫。他们买了自己的杀虫剂。他们把所有的衣服、床单、毛巾、枕头和女儿所有的玩具都放进干净的塑料袋里，生活在塑料袋里。他们扔掉了一半的书，然后把保留下来的书每一页都用吸尘器清理。把它们放进塑料袋。他们用凡士林涂抹床腿，因为斯蒂芬妮在哪儿读到过臭虫无法爬过凡士林。他们负担不起搬家的费用。
Lately it seems to be working. And when you visit their apartment you can't tell anything's wrong. It's clean. It's neat. And when I ask Stephanie if I might see a bed bug somewhere, she doesn't seem sure. But says we might find a stray in the couch she's sitting on. It has dark brown cushions and a dark wood frame. And it's sentimental to Stephanie and her husband, the first piece of furniture they bought when they moved in together. A few years ago to save it from the bed bugs, Stephanie's husband replaced the foam and reupholstered it himself.
最近情况似乎好转了。当你去他们公寓时，你看不出有什么问题。它很干净。整洁。当我问斯蒂芬妮我能否在哪看到一只臭虫时，她看起来不太确定。但说我们可能会在她坐的沙发上找到一只落单的。它有深棕色的靠垫和深色的木框架。这对斯蒂芬妮和丈夫来说很有纪念意义，这是他们搬到一起住时买的第一件家具。几年前为了从臭虫手中拯救它，斯蒂芬妮的丈夫自己更换了泡沫并重新包了布。
You want to see one. I understand.
你想看一只吗。我明白。
(INTERVIEWER) ROBYN SEMIEN: To be honest, I think I don't really want to know the full extent in the couch.
说实话，我觉得我不太想知道沙发里到底有多少。
Let's take a look.
看看吧。
(HOST) ROBYN SEMIEN: She squats by the couch and starts to pull at the corner of the seat cushion.
她在沙发旁蹲下，开始拉动座垫的一角。
Oh. Oh, no. I may actually have a little freak-out.
噢。噢，不。我可能会真的有点崩溃。
(INTERVIEWER) ROBYN SEMIEN: What did you see in there?
你在里面看到了什么？
So there's a little burgeoning bed bug colony. See these folds? This is where like to-- but it's on this side. So you can take a peek, if you like.
里面有一个正在滋生的小臭虫群落。看到这些褶皱了吗？这是它们喜欢……但这在这一面。所以你可以看一眼，如果你想的话。
(INTERVIEWER) ROBYN SEMIEN: I see nothing.
我什么都没看到。
You will.
你会看到的。
(HOST) ROBYN SEMIEN: To me it doesn't look like much, like brown dust or tobacco that's come out of a cigarette and some white powder mixed in.
对我来说它看起来没什么，就像棕色的灰尘或从香烟里掉出来的烟草，混着一些白色粉末。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
(HOST) ROBYN SEMIEN: But it hits Stephanie much harder, like here we go again.
但这对斯蒂芬妮的打击要沉重得多，就像又开始了。
Like actually it looks mostly like grown bed bugs, with a few white-- I haven't been getting that many bites on the couch. But the fact that it's in the upholstery makes it-- there's just nothing to be done. I'll probably go and get the pesticide that we have just so these guys don't get dinner tonight. And then tomorrow I'll ask my husband to take the couch downstairs.
实际上它看起来主要都是成年的臭虫，还有一些白色的……我在沙发上并没有感觉到那么多叮咬。但它在内饰里这个事实让它……真的无能为力。我可能去拿我们有的那种杀虫剂，好让这些家伙今晚别吃晚餐。然后明天我会让我丈夫把沙发搬到楼下。
(INTERVIEWER) ROBYN SEMIEN: I'm sorry.
我很抱歉。
Yeah.
是的。
(HOST) ROBYN SEMIEN: A few years ago Stephanie decided to do an experiment to see how long the bed bugs could live without food, without feeding on her family. She found two baby bed bugs and kept them in a sealed plastic deli container on her window sill. Months passed and instead of dying, they bred. She'd grown a colony of bed bugs, in an apartment of bed bugs, in a building of bed bugs. She ended up tossing the whole thing out because she could and because she was scared they might find a way to escape.
几年前，斯蒂芬妮决定做一个实验，看看臭虫在没有食物、不吸食她家人血液的情况下能活多久。她发现了两只小臭虫，把它们关在窗台上密封的熟食塑料盒里。几个月过去了，它们不仅没死，反而繁殖了。她培育出了一群臭虫，在一个住着臭虫的公寓里，在一栋住着臭虫的楼里。她最后把那盒东西全扔了，因为她能，而且因为她害怕它们可能会找到逃跑的方法。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Robyn Simeon. A week or two after this story first aired on our show a year ago, the landlord of 349 Saint John's Place hired a new exterminator who now treats the building regularly. Stephanie says her apartment has been bug free since.
罗宾·塞米恩。在一年前这个故事在我们节目首播的一两周后，圣约翰广场349号的房东雇了一名新的灭虫员，现在定期对大楼进行处理。斯蒂芬妮说她的公寓从那以后就再也没有虫子了。
Coming up, somebody who consciously trains himself not to fall asleep and then must suffer the consequences. And more. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一个有意识地训练自己不要入睡，然后必须承担后果的人。还有更多。请稍候。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we choose the theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today show, Fear of Sleep. We've arrived at Act Three of our show.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，并带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的主题，对睡眠的恐惧。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。
Act Three. The Bitter Fruits of Wakefulness.
第三幕。清醒的苦果。
We have this story from Joel Lovell. A warning before we start this story to sensitive listeners that this story acknowledges the existence of sex and sexual feelings.
我们有这个来自乔尔·洛弗尔的故事。在开始这个故事前，给敏感听众一个警告：这个故事承认性和性感受的存在。
I've been told that the insomnia I've struggled with on and off for most of my life comes from drinking too much caffeine or eating too much sugar or sleeping on a bed that's too soft or too hard or too flat. That I don't exercise enough or that I exercise too much. Or that I exercise the right amount, but at the wrong time of day. Or that it's the result of watching TV or using a computer right before I go to bed. Though isn't that when everyone pokes around on the computer or watches TV? I've also been told that I should have more sex, which was good to hear. But then I was told I should have less.
有人告诉我，我大半生断断续续受困的失眠症是因为咖啡因喝太多、糖吃太多，或者睡在太软、太硬或太平的床上。因为我运动不够，或者运动太多。或者运动量刚好，但时间不对。或者是因为睡前看电视或用电脑。但难道这不是每个人睡前都会摆弄电脑或看电视的时候吗？我还有人告诉我我应该多做爱，这听起来不错。但后来又有人告诉我我应该少做点。
What my insomnia is really about is being afraid. I don't mean being afraid of something happening to my daughters or to my wife or to my job or whatever other adult fears. I mean it's about being afraid when I was a kid. Specifically when I was 11 years old, the year I trained myself not to sleep.
我的失眠其实是关于恐惧。我不是指害怕我的女儿、妻子、工作或其他成年人的恐惧。我是指当我还是个孩子时的恐惧。确切地说，当我11岁那年，我训练自己不睡觉。
It wasn't that hard. I had all the normal childhood fears to draw on. Pops Ferrara, for instance. He was on my PeeWee football team, a fifth grader just like me. Though he was the kind of fifth grader who could get the nickname Pops. He was squat, and bowlegged, and crazily muscular. And he had a raspy voice that was indistinguishable from the voice of his father, who was also called Pops.
这并不难。我有所有正常的童年恐惧可以利用。比如波普斯·费拉拉。他是我们小联盟足球队的，一个和我一样的五年级生。虽然他是那种能得“波普斯”这个绰号的五年级生。他矮胖，罗圈腿，疯狂的强壮。他有着沙哑的嗓音，和他也被叫波普斯的父亲声音一模一样。
Once in practice, I reached out to slap hands with Pops, the younger. And he took hold of my wrist and turned my hand palm up. And hawked a huge loogie into the center of it. He scared the crap out of me.
有一次训练中，我伸手想和年轻的波普斯击掌。他抓住我的手腕，把我的手心翻过来，朝中间吐了一口浓痰。他把我吓坏了。
It wasn't just Pops, though. I was afraid of the Pawnic twins, with their fantastic breasts and the way they sat on the jungle gym smoking their parents' cigarettes. I was afraid of not doing perfectly in school and then afraid of being the kid who did perfectly in school. I was afraid of hobos. This isn't a joke. We lived on a dead-end street, next to a railroad track. And one night my father woke up and chased two of them out of our house. I was afraid of my father having a heart attack because his father had died of a heart attack when he was a kid and had been buried in the cemetery across the street from his house.
不过不仅是波普斯。我害怕帕尼克双胞胎，她们有着傲人的乳房，坐在攀爬架上抽着父母的烟。我害怕在学校做得不够完美，又害怕成为那个在学校做得完美的孩子。我害怕流浪汉。这不是笑话。我们住的一条死胡同旁就是铁轨。一天晚上，我父亲醒来，把两个流浪汉赶出了我们家。我害怕父亲心脏病发作，因为他父亲小时候死于心脏病，就被埋在他们家对面马路的墓地里。
And I was afraid that when my father died of his heart attack, it would be on a night when my older brother didn't come home until very late, which was happening more and more. He was 17 years old, a senior in high school, and something bad had come undone in him. He'd started going out each night and coming home at midnight and then sometimes at 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning. Wild-eyed and belligerent, saying weird stuff that we attributed to his being drunk or high, but that much later we realized were the first signs of his schizophrenia.
我还害怕，当父亲因心脏病发作去世时，那正好是我哥哥很晚才回家的一天，这种情况发生得越来越多。他17岁，高三，他身上有些不好的东西失控了。他开始每晚出门，午夜回家，有时甚至是凌晨2点或3点。眼神狂野、好斗，说着怪话，我们归因于他喝醉了或吸毒，但很久以后我们才意识到那是他精神分裂症的早期迹象。
My father would sit in the fake leather recliner in our living room, in his boxer shorts and t-shirt, waiting for my brother to come home. And the moment my brother opened the door, the questions and shouting and occasional furniture-toppling fistfight would erupt. I stayed up those nights and watched out my window, waiting for my brother to suddenly appear beneath the streetlamp on our block. One night he stopped there and did an impromptu martial arts kata, punching and kicking the air in front of him for nearly half an hour, in the middle of the circle of white light. As soon as I saw him I'd get out of bed and go into the living room, hoping that my presence there would keep things from escalating, which occasionally it did.
父亲会穿着平角裤和T恤坐在客厅的仿皮躺椅上，等着哥哥回家。哥哥一开门，质问、大吼大叫以及偶尔发生的推倒家具的斗殴就会爆发。那些晚上我一直熬着，在窗边监视，等着哥哥突然出现在我们街区的街灯下。一天晚上，他在那里停下来，即兴表演了一套武术套路，对着空气挥拳踢腿将近半小时，就在那片白光圆圈中。我一看到他就下床走到客厅，希望我的出现能阻止事态升级，有时确实有效。
And so I taught myself not to go to sleep. It was mostly just a matter of queuing up the highlight reel of anxiety and letting the images flicker away inside my head. Pops Ferrara pinning me to the ground and spitting in my face. Or the hobos, who at that very moment were no doubt sitting on the tracks of above our house waiting for the lights to go out. Or my dad's weak heart and what his face would look like when it started to clinch inside his chest.
于是我训练自己不要入睡。这主要就是把焦虑的亮点片段排好，让影像在脑海中闪烁。波普斯·费拉拉把我按在地上，吐在我脸上。或者那些此刻无疑正坐在我们房子上方铁轨上等着灯熄灭的流浪汉。或者我父亲脆弱的心脏，以及当它在他胸口开始紧缩时，他的脸会是什么样子。
I dialed up all the imaginary drama inside my head, which kept me awake, which then allowed me to dial down the very real drama that existed each night inside our house. And it worked. It worked so well in fact that almost immediately there were consequences. By training myself to fear sleep, it became y default mode. I set myself up for a lifetime of late night distress, unproductive self-probing, and troubling discoveries I'd never have made if I hadn't been awake in the middle of the night.
我拨动了脑海中所有想象的戏剧性，这让我保持清醒，这又让我能调低每晚家里存在的真实戏剧性。这有效了。事实上效果太好，几乎立刻就有了后果。通过训练自己恐惧睡眠，它成了我的默认模式。我为自己设定了一辈子的深夜苦恼、无效的自我挖掘，以及如果我没在深夜醒着就永远不会有的不安发现。
The first and maybe the biggest came at the end of our PeeWee football season in the fall of 1977. We'd played all the local teams and won all our games. And so we were selected to play in a PeeWee sanctioned Turkey Bowl in Seaford, Long Island, seven hours away. When our coach gave us the news, all the kids on my team raised their helmets in the air and hooted like they'd seen real players do on TV. What I thought was, oh Jesus, another two weeks of dodging Pops Ferrara, great.
第一次，或许也是最大的一次，发生在1977年秋天我们小联盟足球赛季结束时。我们和所有当地球队比赛并赢了所有比赛。所以我们被选中参加在离这七小时路程的长岛锡福德举办的小联盟认可的“火鸡碗”比赛。当教练告诉我们消息时，我队里所有的孩子都举起头盔欢呼，就像他们在电视上看到的真正职业球员一样。我心里想的是，噢天哪，又要再躲两个星期波普斯·费拉拉，太棒了。
It was worse than that though. We weren't going to bunk together in motel rooms, which would have been bad enough. We were going to stay with the families of players on the opposing team. As you might imagine, I was a kid who dreaded sleeping over at anyone's house, much less a stranger's. In part because of garden variety anxiety, and in part because I worried about what might happen in my own house if I wasn't there. I tried every excuse to get out of it, but nothing worked.
但这比那更糟。我们不是住在汽车旅馆的房间里，那已经够糟糕的了。我们要住在对方球队队员的家里。你可以想象，我是一个害怕在任何人住处过夜的孩子，更不用说是陌生人的家里。部分是因为普通的焦虑，部分是因为担心如果我不在家，自己家里会发生什么。我试过各种借口想逃避，但都没用。
And so when the time arrived, I ate breakfast in silence as my mother packed my lunch. Then rode with my father to the parking lot outside Perkins Pancake House, where I boarded our bus and sat as far away from Pops as possible. Three hundred or so miles later we arrived at another parking lot and car after car pulled up and took my teammates away. Eventually the family I'd be staying with arrived, a big square-headed man with his two sons, smaller versions of him. One a few years older than I was and the other my age. They sat silently on either side of me in the back seat of their station wagon as their father talked about football all the back to their home. Their mother greeted us on their front lawn. Her face was sweet and chubby and she wore a Fighting Irish baseball cap over her Brillo-y hair.
所以时间到了，妈妈打包午餐时我默默地吃着早餐。然后坐父亲的车去了帕金斯薄饼店外的停车场，我上了巴士，尽可能坐得离波普斯远点。三百多英里后，我们到达了另一个停车场，一辆接一辆的车开来，把我的队友接走了。最后，我将要住的那一家人到了，一个大方头男人，带着他的两个儿子，那是他的小版本。一个比我大几岁，另一个和我同龄。当父亲一路滔滔不绝谈论足球回到家时，他们在我坐的旅行车后座两侧默默坐着。他们的母亲在前草坪上迎接我们。她的脸甜美而丰满，戴着一顶“战斗爱尔兰人”棒球帽，盖着她像钢丝球一样的头发。
She put her arm around my shoulders as she led me into their house. It was dark in there, all heavy furniture and curtains and there was Notre Dame paraphernalia all over the place: A Notre Dame blanket and throw pillow on the sofa. A Notre Dame latch hook rug on the dark-paneled family room wall. Notre Dame posters all over the bedroom that the brothers shared.
她搂着我的肩膀领我进屋。屋里很黑，全是厚重的家具和窗帘，到处都是圣母大学的周边：沙发上有圣母大学的毯子和抱枕。暗色木板铺就的家庭活动室墙上挂着圣母大学的钩编地毯。兄弟俩合住的卧室里满是圣母大学的海报。
The kid my age, the one I'd be playing the next day, he barely talked to me. And his older brother spoke only when he wanted to mock the two of us. We sat in their TV room and watched a college football game while the father, who was also an assistant coach of his son's team, unleashed an endless commentary about blocking and short pass routes and the wishbone offense. Before dinner, I stared into my plate as they said grace. We had pot roast and potatoes, which my mother cooked all the time. But this didn't taste like hers. Even their ice cubes had a weird smell to them. And after dessert and more endless football talk we played Atari, which the mother told the two brothers to include me in. She must have sensed my discomfort because before bed she looked into my eyes and said that if there was anything I wanted, they were just down the hall. That it was no bother to wake them if I needed to.
那个和我同龄的孩子，明天比赛我将要对阵的那个，几乎没跟我说过话。而他的哥哥只在想要嘲笑我们俩时才开口。我们坐在电视房看大学足球赛，父亲，也是他儿子的球队助理教练，不停地评论着阻挡、短传路线和许愿骨阵型。晚餐前，我盯着盘子，他们做了祷告。我们吃的是炖牛肉和土豆，我妈常做这种菜。但这味道和她做的不一样。甚至他们的冰块都有一种奇怪的味道。吃完甜点，听完没完没了的足球讨论，我们玩了雅达利游戏，母亲叫两个兄弟带上我。她一定感觉到了我的不适，因为睡前她看着我的眼睛说，如果有任何需要，他们就在走廊那头。需要的话叫醒他们一点也不麻烦。
I slept on the floor in a sleeping bag between the two brothers' beds. They had NFL bedspreads and a Pittsburgh Steelers poster on the ceiling overhead. We talked for a few minutes about the game the next day. And the older brother went on about how my team was going to slaughter his brother's, which was kind of him. And then before long we stopped talking and they both drifted off to sleep.
我睡在地板的睡袋里，在两个兄弟的床之间。他们有NFL的床罩，天花板上挂着匹兹堡钢人队的海报。我们聊了几分钟明天的比赛。哥哥喋喋不休地说我的球队明天会屠杀他弟弟的球队，他真是太客气了。没过多久我们就不说话了，他们俩都沉沉入睡。
I don't know how much time passed. In my memory it's hours, though that can't really be the case. I started thinking of home, wondering if my parents were awake and if my brother was still out. And then I started wondering if the mother here in this house would check on us. When it was clear she wasn't going to, I got up and went to the bathroom and hoped that she'd hear me in there. I turned on the bathroom light and looked in the mirror, flushed the toilet and let the water run for awhile. I didn't know what I'd say to her, but I just wanted her to come out and comfort me in some way. Maybe give me something to drink or some more pie. Or just talk to me for a while about my parents or school or the wishbone offense for all I cared.
不知道过了多久。记忆里是几个小时，尽管那不可能。我开始想家，想父母是否醒着，哥哥是否还没回家。然后我开始想这家里的母亲会不会来看看我们。当确定她不会来时，我起床去了卫生间，希望她能听到我在里面。我打开浴室灯，看了看镜子，冲了马桶，让水流了一会儿。我不知道该对她说什么，但我只是想让她出来以某种方式安慰我。也许给我点喝的或者派。或者只是跟我聊聊我的父母、学校或者什么该死的许愿骨阵型。
I stepped back into the hallway and stood there in my pajamas, listening to the house. The parents were still awake in their room. A light was on. And so I walked to their door and knocked on it, thinking I'd apologize and then ask for a glass of water. I nudged the door open and there was the mother on her bed. And behind her the father, red-faced and naked. I had no idea what I was seeing, just that I shouldn't be. Her head was bent toward the sheets and she never lifted it. He looked right at me. He was pale and fat and there was a scar that ran vertically from his naval. Neither of us said a thing.
我回到走廊，穿着睡衣站在那，听着屋里的动静。父母在他们房间里还没睡。灯亮着。于是我走到他们门前敲了敲，心想我会道歉然后要一杯水。我推开门，看见母亲在床上。她身后是父亲，满脸通红，一丝不挂。我完全不知道我在看什么，只是觉得我不该看。她的头垂向床单，从未抬起。他直直地看着我。他脸色苍白，虚胖，肚脐处有一道垂直的疤痕。我们谁都没说话。
I closed the door and hurried back to the boys' bedroom and waited for something to happen, but nothing did. The next morning the mother would make pancakes and bacon. And the father would come in from outdoors and tussle my hair and say it was a cold day for a football game. Neither of them would hint at what happened in the bedroom. That was all hours away though. I lay there for a while, listening to the sound of the brothers' breathing on either side of me, simultaneously trying to block out and then bring into sharper focus what I had just seen, to make sense of what it all meant. I was 11 years old.
我关上门，赶回男孩们的卧室，等着发生点什么，但什么都没发生。第二天早上，母亲会做薄饼和培根。父亲会从外面进来，揉揉我的头发，说这是一个适合踢足球的寒冷日子。他们谁都没提到卧室里发生的事。那是几个小时以后的事了。我躺在那里，听着两侧兄弟的呼吸声，同时试图屏蔽，然后又将我刚看到的景象聚焦，去理解这一切意味着什么。我才11岁。
My brother, who I was closer to than anyone in the world, was turning into someone I no longer knew. I was lying on a floor in the house of complete strangers. And I'd just opened the door on a large, pale man having sex with his sweet matronly wife, the closest thing to my mother for 300 miles. You just have no idea what's going on at any moment in any family in any house. Pretty much everything in life is an absolute frigging mystery. There was still a lot of night ahead of me.
我最亲近的哥哥正在变成一个我不再认识的人。我躺在一个完全陌生人家里的地板上。我刚推开门，看见一个高大、苍白的男人正在和他的甜美、如慈母般的妻子做爱，这是300英里内最像我母亲的人。你根本不知道任何时刻任何家庭任何房子里正在发生什么。生活中的几乎一切都是一个彻底的该死的谜。我还有很长的夜晚要熬。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Joel Lovell, he teaches in the graduate writing program at the University of Pittsburgh and is an editor at GQ Magazine.
乔尔·洛弗尔，他在匹兹堡大学的研究生写作项目中任教，是《GQ》杂志的编辑。
Hello.
你好。
(INTERVIEWER) SETH LIND: Keith, it's Seth.
基思，我是塞思。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: This is the production manager of our radio show, Seth Lind, calling his uncle Keith about an incident that is actually the subject of this next act, Act Four, an incident that happened to Seth when he should have been sleeping, over 20 years ago.
这是我们广播节目的制作经理塞思·林德，他正在打电话给他的叔叔基思，谈论一件实际上是下一幕——第四幕——主题的事件，一件20多年前塞思应该在睡觉时发生的事件。
(INTERVIEWER) SETH LIND: What I was calling about is I wanted to know if you remembered something, which was there was one night when you were staying over. And I woke up in the middle of the night and you were watching The Shining.
我打电话是想知道你是否记得一件事，就是有一天你来过夜的时候。我半夜醒来，你正在看《闪灵》。
The movie?
那部电影？
(INTERVIEWER) SETH LIND: The movie, The Shining.
那部电影，《闪灵》。
Uhuh.
嗯。
(INTERVIEWER) SETH LIND: Do you remember me watching that with you?
你记得我跟你一起看吗？
I do not.
我不记得了。
(INTERVIEWER) SETH LIND: Really.
真的吗。
I vaguely remember myself watching it.
我隐约记得自己看过。
(INTERVIEWER) SETH LIND: Yeah. I watched almost the whole thing with you. I was six.
是的。我几乎和你一起看完了整部电影。我当时六岁。
You were six years old?
你当时六岁？
(INTERVIEWER) SETH LIND: I was six.
我当时六岁。
OK. I remember bits of the movie.
好吧。我记得电影的一些片段。
(INTERVIEWER) SETH LIND: Do you remember the elevator doors opening and blood rushing out?
你记得电梯门打开、血水涌出来的画面吗？
That I do not.
那个我不记得。
(INTERVIEWER) SETH LIND: Really. Because I remember that was right when I sat down and that happened. And I didn't know what was going on. And you said, "Do you know what that is?" And I said, "Is it mud?" And you said, "No. It's blood."
真的吗。因为我记得我刚坐下时正好发生了那一幕。我不知道发生了什么。你说，“你知道那是什么吗？”我说，“是泥巴吗？”你说，“不。是血。”
Honestly I do not recollect.
老实说我一点印象都没有。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Well, that was totally unsatisfying.
嗯，这太让人失望了。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Yeah.
是的。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: I like how he wasn't sorry in the least.
我喜欢他一点歉意都没有的样子。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Yeah. Like oh, you want to watch a movie too? It's two dudes watching a movie.
是啊。好像在说，噢，你也想看电影吗？这是两个哥们儿在看电影。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Seth had a very common childhood experience. He saw a film he shouldn't have seen. And it had exactly the effect you'd think. After seeing The Shining , he had trouble falling asleep and nightmares every night. And here's where it gets a little extreme, this lasted for most of two years.
塞思有过一段非常普遍的童年经历。他看了他不该看的电影。这产生了你预料之中的确切影响。看完《闪灵》后，他睡觉有了困难，每晚做噩梦。这就是变得有点极端的地方，这种情况持续了将近两年。
It lasted so long probably because the film was The Shining . A film that is not only truly scary, it starred a six-year-old boy-- the same age as Seth at the time. And if you remember The Shining , the director Stanley Kubrick is constantly shooting from the six year old's perspective. There are all those amazing shots down from kid-level height, as the little boy speeds down the hallways of this huge hotel on his big wheel. This made everything in the film seem very, very real to Seth.
之所以持续这么久，可能是因为电影是《闪灵》。这部电影不仅真正吓人，而且主演是一个六岁男孩——和塞思当时的年龄一样。如果你记得《闪灵》，导演斯坦利·库布里克一直在从六岁孩子的视角拍摄。所有那些精彩的镜头都是从孩子眼睛的高度拍摄的，小男孩在大酒店的走廊里骑着三轮车飞驰。这让电影里的一切在塞思看来显得非常、非常真实。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: It just made it plausible. I think it was just a really quick decision, like I'm that kid. As simple as that. It's like oh, hey look. I'm on the TV. And there's really, really, really terrible things happening to me and my family.
这让它变得可信。我想那只是一个非常快速的决定，就像我就是那个孩子。就这么简单。就像是，噢，嘿看。我在电视上。并且我和我的家人正在遭遇极其、极其、极其可怕的事情。
(SUBJECT) DANNY TORRANCE: Mommy. I'm scared.
妈妈。我好怕。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: And I think that's why it got so far under my skin.
我想这就是为什么它如此深入我心。
(SUBJECT) WENDY TORRANCE: Stop it! Stop it!
住手！住手！
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Over the course of a day, I would-- well, first of all I would feel this extreme pleasure in the morning when I woke up because I had gotten through the night. And it was like every day was this relief. But then as the day went on, I would start to feel this dread because I knew I was going to have to go to sleep. I knew it was going to get dark.
一天之中，我会……首先，我会在早上醒来时感到这种极度的快乐，因为我熬过了夜晚。每一天都像是一种解脱。但随着一天过去，我会开始感到这种恐惧，因为我知道我得去睡觉。我知道天要黑了。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: It was like you were doomed.
就像你注定要倒霉一样。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Yeah. It was like I knew exactly what was going to happen.
是啊。就像我知道接下来会发生什么一样。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: And just describe, you would be lying there trying to fall asleep?
描述一下，你躺在那里试图入睡？
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: I'd lie down and really quickly just one of these images would just pop in my mind. I mean the blood coming out of the elevator was huge. Also there are these twin girls who, in the movie, are sort of spectral characters that only Danny, the little kid, can see.
我会躺下，然后很快其中一个画面就会出现在我脑海里。电梯流血的画面印象深刻。还有那一对双胞胎女孩，在电影里，她们是某种只有丹尼，那个小孩子能看到的幽灵角色。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: And they are sort of shot like Diane Arbus twins, sort of spooky, standing side by side, kind of intoning straight to the camera.
她们被拍得像黛安·阿勃丝的双胞胎，有点阴森，并排站着，直接对着镜头念叨。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Exactly. And they're shot inter-cutting between them speaking and pictures of their chopped up corpses. That was the biggest one, the image that would pop into my head the most.
正是。而且拍摄在她们说话的镜头和她们被分尸的尸体图片之间切换。那是最大的一个，最常出现在我脑海里的画面。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: It's interesting you talked to your parents about this on tape a couple weeks ago.
你几周前在录音里跟父母谈过这件事，这很有趣。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Yeah.
是啊。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: And it's clear. Like they knew that something was happening, but somehow they don't know how deep it goes.
很显然。他们知道发生了什么，但不知怎么地，他们不知道深度到了什么地步。
Hold on. Let me just push a button here.
等等。让我按个按钮。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: The protagonist was like a little boy. And I was six. And he must have been around that age or so.
主角是个小男孩。我当时六岁。他一定大概也是那个年纪。
(SUBJECT) MRS. LIND: Was there a little girl too?
还有一个小女孩吗？
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Well, there were two little girls.
嗯，有两个小女孩。
(SUBJECT) MRS. LIND: Oh. Oh, OK.
噢。噢，好吧。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Who were twin sisters, who were murdered.
是双胞胎姐妹，她们被谋杀了。
(SUBJECT) MRS. LIND: Who were murdered. OK.
被谋杀了。好吧。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: So they were ghosts.
所以她们是鬼魂。
(SUBJECT) MRS. LIND: I guess I need to see it again.
我想我得再看一遍。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: And they say--
她们说——
(SUBJECT) GRADY TWINS: Come play with us Danny.
来陪我们玩吧，丹尼。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Come play with us Danny. Come play with us forever.
来陪我们玩吧，丹尼。来陪我们玩吧，永远。
(SUBJECT) GRADY TWINS: Forever. And ever. And ever.
永远。一直一直。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: I love how your mom's take on this is it's so not deeply sinister, this film.
我喜欢你妈妈对此的看法，这部电影一点也不阴险。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: There was a little girl. Didn't he have a friend? He had a playmate.
有个小女孩。他不有个朋友吗？他有个玩伴。
It's not fair for me to expect that someone had to have the same relationship to it as me, feeling like I kind of lived inside of it in a really terrible way.
我指望别人和我有一样的关系是不公平的，我觉得我以一种极其可怕的方式活在电影里。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: For two years.
持续了两年。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: For two years.
两年。
(SUBJECT) MRS. LIND: My most intense memory of the after effects of all that is that I'd wake up in the morning and you'd be sleeping on the floor on the rug beside the bed, all curled up in your quilt.
我对这一切后果印象最深的是，我每天早上醒来，发现你正蜷缩在床边的地毯上，裹着被子。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: I remember going to my room during the day. And I would look at our bedroom and sort of prove to myself that it wasn't scary. During the day.
我记得白天回我的房间。我会看看我们的卧室，证明给自己看它并不吓人。在白天。
(SUBJECT) MRS. LIND: Oh.
噢。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: And because I'd say, OK it's light out. This is exactly what it looks like at night. It's just dark. There's nothing different about it. But I would get this sort of dread as the day went on.
因为我会说，好吧，外面亮着。晚上看起来也是这样。天黑而已。它没什么不同。但随着一天过去，我会产生这种恐惧感。
(SUBJECT) MRS. LIND: And I don't remember that you shared any of that at all.
我不记得你分享过任何这些。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: I don't think I shared any of it.
我不认为我分享过任何。
(SUBJECT) MRS. LIND: I mean to everyone else and throughout your growing up, I mean you were to all outward appearances a really joyful, happy child, really loving. And yet it just really shows that children have very involved inner lives that their parents might not know much about.
我的意思是，对其他人来说，在你成长的过程中，你在外观上是个非常快乐、开心的孩子，非常可爱。然而这确实表明孩子们有非常复杂的内心生活，他们的父母可能对此知之甚少。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Yeah.
是啊。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: And why didn't you ask for help?
为什么你不寻求帮助？
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: I didn't think that anyone could help. The message of the movie is no one's going to help you little kid.
我不认为有人能帮忙。电影传达的信息是，没人会帮助你这个小孩子。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: The parents in the film just aren't any help to the kid. Like your parents aren't going to help you.
电影里的父母根本对孩子没用。就像你的父母帮不了你一样。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Right. The father in the movie is trying to kill you. The mother wants to save you, but can't. You have to save yourself.
没错。电影里的父亲想要杀死你。母亲想救你，但救不了。你必须自救。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Do you think one of the reasons why you didn't ask for help was because it was-- it's like because it affected your dreams. Do you know what I mean?
你认为你不寻求帮助的原因之一是因为它……是因为它影响了你的梦境吗？你懂我的意思吗？
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Yeah.
是啊。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Like in a way it had gotten to a part of you where nobody can go anyway but you.
就像它以一种方式渗透到了你身体里，除了你以外没人能去的地方。
(SUBJECT) SETH LIND: Right. There's a certain point where the person who is trying to help you is going to go to sleep. And I would be left alone. Everyone sleeps alone.
没错。到了某个点，那个试图帮你的人就会去睡觉。而我会被独自留下。每个人都是独自入睡的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Seth Lind. He's not just our program's production manager, he is also in the comedy troupe, Thank You, Robot.
塞思·林德。他不仅是我们节目的制作经理，还是喜剧剧团“谢谢，机器人”的成员。
[MUSIC - "SLEEPWALKER" BY BROTHER ALI]
[音乐 - 《梦游者》 BY 阿里的兄弟]
Act Five. A Little taste of the Big Sleep.
第五幕。长眠的一小口滋味。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: So I started today's show by talking about how fear of sleeping for me goes hand in hand with the fear of death. And I used to be surprised that everybody didn't feel that way or regularly have that experience, these moments in bed when they felt so aware that death is really going on happen to them. And I have found that it is comforting that there are other people who do feel that. Here are some.
所以我今天节目的开头谈到了，对我来说，害怕睡觉与害怕死亡是如影随形的。我曾经很惊讶，为什么不是每个人都有那种感觉，或者经常有那种经历——在床上感到死亡真的会发生在他们身上的瞬间。我发现有人也感到这种恐惧是件让人宽慰的事。这些人就是。
(SUBJECT) JANE FELTES: I will be totally asleep. And it'll be about 3:00 or 4:00 o'clock in the morning. I'll just bolt upright. I'm like gasp!
我会睡得很死。大约是凌晨3点或4点。我猛地坐起来。我像是倒吸一口凉气！
(SUBJECT) MAN 1: Then it's like a complete instant panic attack where I'm just like clutching the sheets and going oh god, oh god, oh no, oh god, oh no.
那就像是一场即时的恐慌发作，我紧紧抓住床单，心想噢天，噢天，噢不，噢天，噢不。
(SUBJECT) JANE FELTES: And I just like kind of hang onto the bed and be like no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. And I'm just wanting to scream.
我只是紧紧抓住床不放，心想不，不，不，不……我只想尖叫。
(SUBJECT) MAN 2: Your cornered. You're a trapped animal who's like sweating and waiting for its head to be chopped off.
你被逼到了角落。你是一只被困的动物，浑身冒汗，等着头颅被砍下来。
(SUBJECT) MAN 1: I can feel time whizzing by. And I'm trying to hold on to something generally. So I usually start grabbing the walls or like clinging to the pillow. And I'm like this isn't going to go away. I need to hold this. I need to hold on to time. I need to stand in this river and just not move.
我能感觉到时间飞逝。我通常试图抓住什么东西。所以我通常开始抓墙，或者死死抱住枕头。我心想这不会消失的。我需要抓住这个。我需要抓住时间。我需要站在河里，只是不动。
(SUBJECT) MAN 2: Like it's a kind of very primitive feeling. You have to just, like, flee from this totally horrible thing that's happening to you. But there is nowhere you can flee. And understanding at the same time that what you're fleeing and trying to run away from is the complete cessation of you.
那是一种非常原始的感觉。你必须逃离这种正在发生在你身上极其可怕的事情。但你无处可逃。同时你也明白，你正在逃避和试图摆脱的是你自己的完全停止。
(SUBJECT) MAN 1: Like normally I think you go through the day and you don't really think you're going to die. Or it seems comforting. Like I'm in traffic this morning, I think, oh I might die someday. I'm like oh, what a relief. I don't have to do this anymore. But there's something about being half asleep specifically that causes the realization to actually take effect.
平时我想你度过白天时，并没有真的觉得你会死。或者这看起来很让人安慰。比如今早我在交通中，我想，噢，我总有一天会死。我心想，噢，解脱了。我不用再做这些了。但在半睡半醒的状态下，会有某种东西导致这种认知真正生效。
(SUBJECT) JANE FELTES: When this wakes me up in the middle of the night it's because I'm right. Like it's going to happen. That's why. Because that's reality. And just for some reason I can see it.
当这种情况在半夜把我唤醒时，是因为我是对的。就像它真的会发生。就是这样。因为那才是现实。只是因为某种原因我能看到。
(SUBJECT) MAN 2: It's not irrational fear. It's like you understand that you're mortal. Your life is going to be over at some point. You're fighting like the worst enemy in the world as you lie there in bed, rolling around in your sheet covers-- in your blankets. And you're rolling around there, trying to fight death. And there's no way you can win.
这不是非理性的恐惧。就像你明白自己会死。你的生命总有一天会结束。你正躺在床上，在你的床单、你的毯子里翻滚，像在和世界上最坏的敌人战斗。你在那里翻滚，试图与死亡对抗。而你无论如何都赢不了。
(SUBJECT) JANE FELTES: I cry. And I just get really sad. And I just think. I try to breath. I breath really deeply. And I just think like there's nothing I can do. Like the terror is overyaken by just sadness. I just want it to not be true.
我哭了。我感到非常悲伤。我只是思考。我试着呼吸。我深呼吸。我心想，我无能为力。就像恐惧被纯粹的悲伤所取代。我只是希望那不是真的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Jane Feltes, Lennard Davis, and DJ [? Ectencamp. ?]
简·费尔特斯，伦纳德·戴维斯，以及DJ。
I know that we almost never have poems on our show. And I already read one poem today, so whatever. But there's a Philip Larkin poem that is exactly about this subject that we're talking about it. It is in his Collected Poems , which is published by Farrar, Straus and Giroux called "Aubade." And it begins and it's nighttime. And he writes at nighttime, you can see what's always been there, unresting death holding your now. And then I'm just going to pick up in the middle of this, where he describes what he sees.
我知道我们几乎从不在节目里读诗。我今天已经读过一首诗了，所以无所谓吧。但菲利普·拉金有一首诗正好讨论我们正在谈论的这个主题。它收录在他由法勒、斯特劳斯和吉鲁出版社出版的《收集诗集》中，题为《晨曲》。它开始于深夜。他写道，在深夜，你可以看到那一直都在的东西，那不安的死亡正握住你的当下。我只在中间选一段，描述他所看到的。
--the total emptiness forever, the sure extinction that we travel to and shall be lost in always. Not to be here, not to be anywhere, and soon; nothing more terrible, nothing more true.
——永远彻底的空虚，我们前往并将永远迷失其中的确切灭亡。不在那里，不在任何地方，且很快；没有比这更可怕的，没有比这更真实的了。
This is a special way of being afraid no trick dispels. Religion used to try, that vast moth-eaten musical brocade created to pretend we never die, and specious stuff that says no rational being can fear a thing it will not feel, not seeing that this is what we fear-- no sight, no sound, no touch or taste or smell, nothing to think with, nothing to love or link with, the anesthetic from which none come round.
这是一种特殊的、任何技巧都无法驱散的恐惧。宗教曾试图，那件巨大的、被虫蛀的音乐锦缎，创造出来以假装我们永远不会死，还有那些诡辩，说理性存在者不会害怕它不会感受到的东西，没看到这正是我们所害怕的——没有视觉、声音、触觉、味觉或嗅觉，没什么可思考的，没什么可爱的或连接的，那是谁都无法从中复苏的麻醉剂。
And so it stays just on the edge of vision, a small unfocused blur, a standing chill that slows each impulse down to indecision. Most things may never happen: this one will, and realization of it rages out in furnace-fear when we are caught without people or drink. Courage is no good: It means not scaring others. Being brave lets no one off the grave. Death is no different whined at than withstood.
于是它就留在视野边缘，一个小小的、失焦的模糊，一种让每一个冲动都减速到犹豫不决的寒冷感。大多数事情可能永远不会发生：但这件一定会，当你身边没有人和酒时，这种认知的实现会在炉火般的高温恐惧中爆发。勇气没用：那意味着不惊吓他人。勇敢并不能让任何人逃脱坟墓。死亡无论是被哀求还是被抵御，都毫无差别。
Slowly light strengthens, and the room takes shape. It stands plain as a wardrobe, what we know, have always known, know that we can't escape, yet can't accept. One side will have to go. Meanwhile telephones crouch, getting ready to ring in locked-up offices, and all the uncaring intricate rented world begins to rouse. The sky is white as clay, with no sun. Work has to be done. Postmen like doctors go from house to house.
光线慢慢变强，房间显出轮廓。它就像一个衣柜一样平实，那是我们知道的，一直知道的，知道我们无法逃脱，却无法接受。总得有一方消失。与此同时，电话在锁住的办公室里蹲守，准备响起，所有无心的、复杂的租赁世界开始苏醒。天空像粘土一样白，没有太阳。工作必须完成。邮递员像医生一样挨家挨户走着。
Well, our show was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltis, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help Seth Lind and PJ Vogt. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好了，我们节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我制作，参与的还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·费尔蒂斯、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩和艾丽莎·希普。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨负责我们的网站。制作助理是塞思·林德和PJ·沃格特。音乐协助是杰西卡·霍珀。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains why he shows up for work sometimes with no shirt, torn pants, no shoes, this way: I'm the Hulk. I'm the Hulk. I'm the Hulk.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督是我们老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他这样解释为什么他有时不穿衬衫、破裤子、不穿鞋来上班：我是绿巨人。我是绿巨人。我是绿巨人。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。